bon sens nous sommes lundi 19 octobre
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal on
commence tout de suite avec les titres
de votre actualité locale grève dans les
médiathèques de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines
le personnel a manifesté samedi contre
les réductions d'effectifs
ils demandent plus d'agents inauguration
officielle pour l'estac à l'école
supérieure des techniques aéronautiques
et de construction automobile
anciennement implantée à levallois a
présenté vendredi son nouveau campus à
50 ans divine et enfin une maison
paroissiale pour les jeunes la maison
jean paul ii est en cours a pour
vocation d'accueillir et de réunir en un
même lieu différents mouvements et
équipes de jeunes d'elancourt mort pas
nous inviter l'abbé corentin castex
victoire de la big air de la paroisse et
gaëlle gesbert responsable de
l'aumônerie les siennes nous en
parlerons
et pour commencer à ce journal une
information un incendie s'est déclaré
hier soir dimanche vers 22h45 dans le
lycée d'hôtellerie et de tourisme de
guyancourt place françois rabelais le
sinistre a été maîtrisé peu après une
heure du matin les pompiers ainsi que
des moyens importants de secours ont été
mobilisés notamment dix véhicules et
engins et 20 personnes ont été évacuées
par précaution
aucune dégradation n'était constatée et
aucun relogement est à prévoir non plus
chum et le référendum pour l'union du
parti socialiste s'est terminée hier
soir elle dure et donc de vendredi à
dimanche les sympathisants de gauche
étaient appelés à répondre à la question
suivante face à la droite et l'extrême
droite
souhaitez-vous l'unité de la gauche et
des écologistes aux élections régionales
et citoyens pouvaient voter sur internet
ou dans des lieux de vote est défini il
y en avait plusieurs dans les yvelines
dimanche mais dix étaient sur le marché
de dot notre dame de versailles que des
militants étaient présents une urne
était à disposition pour les vous pour
les votants on écoute
isabelle this saint jean vice président
de la région en charge de l'enseignement
supérieur et de la recherche au micro de
miquel et demi d'euros j'espère vraiment
que
que tous ceux qui ont des convictions de
gauche et des convictions écolos vont se
rendre compte du moment dans lequel on
est qu'il faut avancer ensemble qu'il
faut travailler ensemble coquet
peut-être que tout n'est pas parfait
qu'il ya des choses il ya des déceptions
mais que l'essentiel quand même élan et
qu' il faut pas oublier en le front
national ne faut pas oublier la droite
on a face à lyon une droite très dure
vraiment très dur donc ne l'oublions pas
et essayons de travailler ensemble dans
le dialogue dans le compromis alors dans
toute la france le oui l'a largement
emporté le premier secrétaire du parti
socialiste jean christophe cambadélis a
annoncé après la consultation que 250 1
1327 personne c'est précis avait voté et
que louis avait récolté 89 % des
suffrages à noter cette information à
prendre avec précaution des organes des
irrégularités auraient pu avoir lieu
dans les votes sur internet et dans les
urnes selon des sources journalistiques
est toujours en politique la section
départementale du modem a organisé jeudi
soir dernier une conférence sur le thème
de l'apprentissage et de la formation
professionnelle les centristes ont
présenté à cette occasion leurs
programmes sur cette problématique en
ile-de-france pour les élections
régionales de décembre prochain
une dizaine de personnes ont participé à
cet événement on écoute amorin la
présidente de la fédération du modem en
seine et marne
elle était au micro de michael et demi
d'euros il ya un réel problème de la
vision sur l'apprentissage les familles
déjà c'est pas l'orientation la plus
on va dire la plus valorisée la plus
valorisante au jeu des familles des
jeunes qui se lance dans l'apprentissage
et puis il ya un réel problème oui il ya
qu'à voir certain nombre
d'établissements je pense aux cci qui
sont obligés de fermer des
établissements faute de fautes de jeunes
qui souhaitent qu'ils peuvent se former
et être de futurs apprentis donc senti
quand même assez long il sur les
problématiques de la police âge et je
vous le disais en titre ce samedi le
personnel des huit médiathèques de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines étaient en grève les agents
manifester contre les réductions
d'effectifs près de 100 % d'entre eux
étaient mobilisés selon les syndicats au
moment du tournage de ce reportage
mélanie poké et patrick jacques de
dixmude distribution de tracts
informations aux usagers cette scène
s'est répétée toute la journée devant
les huit médiathèque saint-quentinoise
devant celle de magny les hameaux une
trentaine de personnes s'étaient
rassemblées en ligne de mire les
problèmes d'effectifs du réseau des
médiathèques
on est moins pour les ouvertures on est
moins de services publics
on est moins pour les médiations qu'est
ce qu'on va faire on va fermer
c'est difficile de faire de faire
toujours autant d'animations autant de
services avec beaucoup moins de
personnel on peut plus là le personnel
demande aussi le remplacement des 14
postes vacants manquant aux agents du
réseau
on vous réclame aussi la titularisation
des treize contractuels qui sont sur le
réseau qui sont des personnels qualifiés
qui ont été formés pour certains depuis
plusieurs années par la caisse qui est
qui sont renouvelés pas toujours
et des fois qu'ils sont remerciés a même
pas quinze jours de la fin de leur
contrat pour continuer à manifester leur
mécontentement
les agents ont mis en ligne une pétition
ce week-end elle recueille à ce jour une
centaine de signatures est du côté de la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines on précise que
la majorité souhaite renforcer le réseau
des médiathèques nouveau travail à
renforcer avec les activités de poésie
et de culture scientifique et les
travaux de la médiathèque du grand canal
financé à hauteur de 6 millions d'euros
des discussions sont en cours avec les
différents acteurs en ce qui concerne
les emplois vacants écouter michel
laugier le président de la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
nous sommes aujourd'hui en recrutement
de cinq agents de par médiathèque
aimé-césaire et anatole france ainsi que
le responsable du débit aux bus donc les
choses sont en cours de jeu peut pas
aller plus vite et pour moi il ya la
question de regretter par défaut encore
faut-il avoir les collaborateurs qui
sont à la hauteur de leur mission et la
crèche gavroche situé dans le quartier
la plaine de neauphle attrape a inauguré
jeudi dernier ses locaux réhabilités
durant l'été cette crèche accueillir 84
enfants en temps complet ou à temps
partiel
des travaux ont été financés par la
commune de trappes est en partie par la
caisse des allocations familiales des
yvelines regardez ce reportage de
mélanie potier peintures refaites salle
de bain plus petit espace de vue plus
spacieux ou encore création de nouveaux
accès la crèche communale gavroche s'est
refait une beauté
les locaux ont été transformés modifier
ce qui donne plus d'espacé pour les
enfants plus de pièces utilisées pour
les enfants et puis bien évidemment
quand on est dans des locaux
et beau
frey rafraîchi coloré et en même temps
et en même temps assez doux c'est un
plus et pour les enfants et bien
évidemment pour le personnel
financé à hauteur de 315 mille euros par
la commune de trappes avec la
participation de la caf des yvelines
les travaux ont été réalisés durant
l'été entraînant la fermeture de la
structure
la crèche gavroche à 84 enfants
essentiellement de la plaine de nos flux
elle n'a pas été en activité pendant les
travaux
on a travaillé avec les parents de
pinson a transféré les enfants pendant
six semaines soit les parents étaient en
vacances auquel cas il n'y avait pas de
souci chez les assistantes familiales ou
bien chez d'autres dans d'autres locaux
de crèches collectives une dernière
phase de travaux concernera la cuisine
la lingerie et la buanderie pour de
l'entretien et des mises aux normes
ces travaux sont prévues pour 2016 et
nous accueillons avec nous en plateau
coréen castet excès ab et vicaire de la
paroisse des longs cours eliel gesbert
responsable de l'aumônerie lycéennes ont
formé cieux et celui-ci est d'avoir
répondu à notre invitation et d'être
venu ce soir sur notre plateau vous êtes
ici pour nous parler de la maison jean
paul ii son inauguration
celui tiennent donc la maison jean paul
ii a été inauguré à elancourt elle se
situe dans ce que vous connaissez
peut-être comme le bilbo l'ancienne
salle de musique pour les jeunes de la
mairie d'elancourt qui étaient ensuite
transformé en restaurant chinois une
maison qu'il ya eu beaucoup de vies et
qui est aujourd'hui destinés aux jeunes
on en parle dans un instant juste après
ce reportage regarder
dieu
deschamps pour célébrer le baptême de la
maison jean paul 2 inauguré ce week-end
à elancourt elle est destinée aux jeunes
de l'éveil de la foi jusqu'à leur entrée
dans l'âge adulte
le projet était attendue depuis près de
sept ans j'attends énormément de choses
notamment un accueil de toutes les
personnes qui sont à côté avec les
différentes maisons étudiantes qui ont
ouvertes à côté avant on avait un centre
oecuméniques où on pouvait se retrouver
entre jeunes est là aujourd'hui on a on
on avait notre dame on avait saint
pierre mais c'est pas des lieux qu'on
pouvait s'approprier et du coup cette
maison ça va nous permettre d'avoir un
endroit où on va dire on se retrouve
tous ensemble des ateliers des
permanences sont prévues catéchèse
aumôneries ou encore des groupes de
paroles spécial à l'occasion des
journées mondiales de la jeunesse
la maison a aussi une vocation
missionnaire l'évangélisation par les
jeunes et pour les jeunes l'idée de
cette maison c'est pouvoir répondre aux
questions et de transmettre la foi à la
fois ceux qui connaissent déjà
dieu et ceux qui se pose simplement des
questions qui sens qui cherche un sens à
leur existence
une messe a été célébrée par l'évêque de
versailles pour cette occasion
il voit dans cette maison un symbole de
renouveau la population est en train de
se renouveler
doucement mais réellement on a besoin
d'eux que les jeunes générations
prennent leur vraiment leur place
sept cent vingt mille euros ont été
nécessaires pour le chantier de la
maison un investissement financé par des
dons des chantiers du cardinal et du
diocèse de versailles tournée vers les
jeunes cette initiative s'inscrit dans
la lignée du pontificat du pape jean
paul ii et du pape françois alors
monsieur on l'a vu dans le reportage
cette maison était à dent dure depuis à
près de 7 ans pour laquelle je me tourne
vers vers vous c'est une histoire tout à
fait en tout cas c'est un
un projet porté par la paroisse depuis
du coup un certain nombre d'années il
manquait un lieu un lieu pour toutes les
activités des jeunes un lieu où les
jeunes puissent se rencontrer et se
soudent se soutenir dans la foi
l'approfondir et pouvoir se préparer à
la transmettre à en témoigner
on voyait dans le reportage donc il ya
des qui il manque un lieu comme ça vous
êtes là depuis assez longtemps vous êtes
responsable de l'aumônerie des lycéens
c'était vraiment un lieu qui manquait
pour les jeunes tout à fait il manquait
un réel lieu de vie on le voit bien si
tu ne savais pas une salle paroissiale
c'est une maison et une maison ça c'est
un lieu de vie un lieu dans lequel on
peut accueillir on peut écouter on peut
aussi transmettre et c'est vraiment la
vocation de cette maison et c'est ce qui
manquait on a une population qui est
sûre elle encourt maurepas
ces jeunes 40 % de la population a moins
de 30 ans il y as on a la chance d'avoir
deux foyers étudiants qui sont présents
à proximité de ce lieu c'est vraiment
c'était vraiment pour nous très
important d'avoir un lieu pour
accueillir toute cette jeunesse et pour
pouvoir transmettre la foi dans les
images on le voyait beaucoup de monde
donc à cette inauguration était célébrée
on se rend pas bien compte qu'il ya ptet
dans cette maison alors que va-t-on y
trouver telles quelles sont les choses
que les gens vont trouver d'ailleurs à
des ateliers bien en fait cette maison
va accueillir tout ce que la paroisse
peut proposer aux jeunes pour recevoir
et transmettre la foi pour l'approfondir
il y aura ce que la france fait déjà
c'est à dire le catéchisme l'aumônerie
pour les collégiens et lycéens un lieu
d'approfondissement de la foi est aussi
ce que nous pourrons proposer pour les
étudiants qui vivent sur les villes d'el
encore et maurepas
il ya effectivement juste en face de la
maison un énorme foyer étudiant du crous
d'au moins 200 places il y à un foyer
étudiant qui est aussi présent près de
la gare de la verrière il y en a un qui
est en construction
il ya toute la vie étudiante est en
train de se réorganiser va sur saint
quentin en yvelines ya l'ouverture de
l'estaca qui a été faite ce week-end
nous voudrions pouvoir permettra
seulement d'étudiants tous ces jeunes
étudiants de pouvoir se poser la
question de en quoi consiste la foi
chrétienne et pourquoi ce que dieu peut
faire pour eux dans leur vie nous
voudrions pouvoir leur proposer de
découvrir la joie de les venger des
jeunes c'est effectivement les deux ce
que ce que nous voyons c'est que il
manqué pour ces jeunes un lieu de vie
qui leur permettent et bien de grandir
dans la foi ensemble en se rencontrant
que les différents âges se croisent se
connaissent et en même temps on sentait
bien dans la paroisse que nous n'avions
pas grand chose à proposer notamment à
l'âge étudiants et c'était important de
pouvoir avoir un lieu pour le faire et
on sent un besoin dans les rencontres
avec les jeunes que nous avons
moi dans mon ministère de prêtre je
rends compte aussi beaucoup d'étudiants
et ils ont soif de comprendre la
cohérence de la foi chrétienne
aujourd'hui dans la société la place des
religions est parfois un peu malmené
beaucoup se posent la question de savoir
mais finalement pourquoi ça paraît si
important pour plein de monde de croire
en dieu et alors nous nous avons un
trésor immense que nous voudrions
partager faire découvrir parce que nous
sommes persuadés qu'il y va de la du
bonheur profond de chaque personne
bizarre vous occuper également des
lycéens c'est ce qui vous de ce site
vous demande vous avez des demandes
voilà ils veulent se retrouver parler
entre autres n'est pas juste aller à
l'église parce que c'était un peu trop
solennel parfois pour des jeunes il ya
une double demande évidemment il ya une
demande qui à la fois une demande de
formation pouvoir comprendre et vivre la
foi il est nécessaire de la transmettre
il y aussi nécessaire de se retrouver
parle de communauté chrétienne qui s'est
vraiment une réelle une réelle famille
et pour qu'une famille vivent
il faut une maison et c'est vraiment ce
que cette maison représente pour nous
les lycéens sont déjà rentrés dans cette
maison samedi et pour eux c'est une
réelle joie de pouvoir se retrouver dans
un lieu et retrouvé six dans un lieu
tous les autres jeunes de la paroisse
qu'ils soient plus petits qu'eux ou plus
grand ce qui seront ce qu'ils sont même
leur flore exemple dans la foi c'est ces
étudiants qui continue à s'engager pour
l'église
alors là la maison a aussi une vraie à
vocation de mission la mission
d'évangélisation comment ça va un peu se
passe et comment ça se déroule c'est
vraiment des jeunes qui veulent le même
qui se proposent pour aller parler à
d'autres
oui tout à fait quand on a le bonheur de
croire et la vraie joie que ça nous
apporte on ne peut qu'avoir envie de la
transmettent est de permettre au plus
grand nombre de découvrir cette joie de
l'évangile cette joie d'être d'être
sauvé par par jésus christ alors c'est
cela va depuis les débuts de l'église
avec la fois ce désir de la transmettre
au plus grand nombre et c'est un désir
qui est habite aussi bien les jeunes que
nos aînés dans la foi mais qu'est ce
qu'ils recherchent vraiment vers les
jeunes s'ils recherchent des cds
réponses à leurs questions cd
les aider dans leur orientation je pense
que fondamentalement chaque homme
recherche le bonheur et et chez les
jeunes et particulièrement les jeunes
étudiants qui se retrouvent confrontés à
beaucoup de questions la question
notamment de l'orientation comme vous le
disiez mais aussi la question de ce que
l'on veut faire réellement dans notre
vie nous nous engager dans le mariage
vous nous engager dans des voies qui
vont être différentes
et tous ces questionnements sont
fondamentalement ceux du bonheur quelle
est la voie qui va nous mener au bonheur
est bon pour pour nous chrétiens ce
bonheur c'est de vie cette vie en jésus
christ comme tracteur castex est
important que cette mission
d'évangélisation soit mené par des
jeunes ce que je sais pas peut-être que
je pense que le le meilleur signe pour
pour bien faire comprendre que la
religion n'est pas une une sorte
d'idéologie qui s'imposerait est qui et
qui du coup devrait être accueillie de
manière forcée est bien c'est que des
jeunes puissent montrer leur joie de
vivre la foi chrétienne et depuis de la
partager il ya vrai véritablement un
trésor quelque chose de l'ordre d'un
trésor qui a partagé
du coup on va proposer à nos jeunes
étudiants qui le souhaitent qu'ils le
désirent de pouvoir inviter de leurs
amis des étudiants qui vivent autour à
des à des soirées dans cette maison on
commence avec une première proposition
de jeudi de jeudi soir on propose un
dîner pour les étudiants qui le
souhaitent à 2 euros où chacun peut
venir avec ses amis
aussi en apportant des questions et nous
discutons tout simplement sur sur des
thèmes de la foi chrétienne
c'est soirée s'appelle les gedinne c'est
facile à 2 euros le jeudi à 20h à la
maison jean paul ii au centre 17 mains
du mal à communiquer avec les jeunes la
religion c'est sa touche
je pense que recevoir un message de la
religion il faut qu'ils soient présentés
par différentes personnes c'est pas la
même chose de parler de la foi avec
quelqu'un qui qui qui la découvre et
qu'il approfondit à 19 20 ans qu'avec
quelqu'un qui l'a déjà vécue depuis 30
ans 40 ans et qui peut apporter le beau
témoignage une fidélité et aussi d'une
joie profonde d'avoir vécu grandi avec
et de continuer encore à vivre avec la
fois je pense que ce sont des
témoignages complémentaires et qui sont
importants de recevoir donc c'est cette
maison c'était un peu créé dans la
livrée du pontificat de jean paul ii
bien sûr aussi du pape françois c'est un
moyen de redynamiser de rajeunir en fait
l'image de l'église
je crois que il ya effectivement une
sorte de plus grande visibilité des
jeunes dans l'église depuis la création
des jmj par le pape jean paul ii
effectivement
je pense aussi qu'il ya maintenant pour
les chrétiens une prise de conscience
que qu'ils ont quelque chose à proposer
qui n'est pas connu de leurs
contemporains
je pense qu'ils 50 ans en arrière
la foi chrétienne imprégner davantage
les pratiques sociales ou en tout cas
les traditions chrétiennes et la foi
chrétienne dans ce qu'elle a dans son
authenticité et bien pouvait être un
petit peu camouflée sous un certain
nombre de pratiques etc
et c'est une des raisons d'ailleurs du
grand recul delà de la pratique de la
foi chrétienne en france et aujourd'hui
les jeunes voileux le décalage qu'il ya
entre la perception qu'ont les gens de
la foi chrétienne et leur propre manière
de la vivre alors une dernière à qui ce
temps avant de nous quitter
est ce que vous pouvez me revoilà gallen
tous les objectifs de la maison à
quelles vont être les grands projets
alors les objectifs de la maison sont
très simple c'est donc déjà de
poursuivre dans un nouveau lieu ce qui
se fait déjà actuellement mais aussi de
pouvoir multiplier les propositions à
l'égard du monde étudiant
sachant que ces propositions forcément
s'adapter aux demandes aux questions
profondes que les jeunes eux mêmes vont
poser en ce moment sur la paroisse avec
elle et d'autres que nous avons vu dans
le reportage nous préparons les jmj de
cet été à cracovie où nous emmenons tous
les jeunes qui souhaitent vivre cet
événement de l'église important et en
même temps c'est une manière pour
beaucoup de jeunes aussi de pouvoir
découvrir davantage l'église et le
message formidable qu'elle qu'elle porte
et transmet françois nous appelle à ne
pas être des chrétiens de salon mais
vraiment des chrétiens qui s'engagent
dans la vie et notamment la vie de leur
ville et quoi de plus beau pour
s'impliquer dans notre vie locale que
d'être vraiment au coeur au coeur du
centre ville d'elancourt au coeur de la
vie de cette cette paroisse eh bien
merci beaucoup monsieur je rappelle donc
le prochain événement c'est un jeudi
soir à 20 heures pour aller dîner d
euros devrait plus d'informations sur le
site de la maison à jean paul ii sur la
page facebook de la maison jean paul ii
et qui plaît
ya même une page facebook pour vous
renseigner n'hésitez pas à y aller et en
parlant d'étudiants justement l'estac à
l'école supérieure des techniques
aéronautiques et de construction
automobile anciennement appelée en
planque implantée à levallois vient
d'inaugurer son nouveau campus à saint
quentin en yvelines
elle fait partie du projet technologique
paris saclay qui vise à regrouper grands
écoles universités et entreprises
privées afin de créer un pôle
d'excellence scientifique comparable à
la silicon valley écoutez les précisions
de fanny bourdon installés sur le
territoire de paris saclay l'estaca
école d'ingénieurs spécialisée dans les
transports a fêté ce vendredi après midi
son ouverture récente à montigny le
bretonneux s'est aussi renforcée par
rapport aux autres territoires de paris
saclay et à ce grand projet même plus
qu'un projet à cette grande réalité
d'universités paris saclay renforcer le
pôle yvelinois le cette université qui
est fortement dédié aux technologies et
à l'innovation dans les technologies
dans les systèmes et l'estaca apporte sa
pierre à ce projet
c'est michel laugier le maire de la
ville qui a inauguré ce nouveau campus
en présence de valérie pécresse en
campagne pour les régionales et du
député david douillet il nous explique
pourquoi l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines est le lieu idéal
pour cette école d'ingénieurs d'adja
très beau campus universitaire qui se
complète aujourd'hui avec l'estac à
nesta car en plus ce qui est au coeur
quand même des grandes entreprises de
l'aéronautique et de l'automobile qui
sont implantés sur notre territoire dont
je crois que tout est là pour que la
réussite soit au rendez vous thales
airbus ou encore peugeot citroën les
entreprises du secteur aéronautique et
automobile ne manquent pas dans la
région
l'occasion aussi pour l'estac à de
consolider son réseau de partenaires et
comme à chaque lundi il est temps de
parler culture avec la chronique de
sephora namani vent sera fort à nos
sorts florane alors ce soir je vous
emmène faire un tour d'horizon autour de
la programmation consacrée en ce moment
un louis xiv et surtout au tri
centenaire de sa mort mort survenue le
1er septembre 10 715 des suites de la
gangrène le premier événement que je
souhaite vous présenter
c'est l'exposition qui se tient à las
bibliothèque municipale de versailles
jusqu'au 16 janvier une exposition
intitulée louis de versailles qui
retrace la vie de ce monarque et le sort
de la ville modelé par la seule volonté
royale louis xiv ou voulant à tout prix
quitter paris affectionnant versailles
pour ces terrains de chasse
la bibliothèque municipale les archives
communales l'école des beaux-arts de
versailles et le musée lambinet ont
conjugué leurs collections pour offrir
au public des pièces exceptionnelles
comme l'acte de naissance de louis xiv
des estampes contemporaines et gravures
d'origine également une exposition
jusqu'au 14 février qui se tient au
musée promenade de port marly intitulé
être aux femmes sous louis xiv du mythe
à la réalité
l'occasion de découvrir l'étiquette à
laquelle les femmes devaient se plier et
le rôle qui leur était dévolu
alors il ya des expositions mais le sait
un colloque est organisé par la société
des amis de port royal de mercredi à
vendredi dernier ses ports exactement
alors ce colloque se tenait sur trois
jours autant trois lieux différents le
mercredi 14 octobre au lycée jules ferry
de versailles pour un programme autour
des grandes figures ayant côtoyé louis
xiv tels que racine historiographe du
roi madame de maintenon bossuet le jeudi
à la bibliothèque municipale de
versailles pour échanger sur les
mémorialistes du roi soleil enfin le
vendredi à port royal pour évoquer les
grandes questions ecclésiale alors se
sont imaginé des spécialistes qui ont
parlé donc du personnage tout à fait
exactement ce sont des spécialistes qui
et on clique on situe en fait cette
société qui s'appelle la société des
amis de port royal et philippe lhez vous
décrira mieux que moi les composants de
cette société la société des amis de
pauriol a été créée dans les années 50
en même temps que l'état créé le musée
de port royal
c'est une société qui associe des
universitaires travaillant sur port
royal en histoire en lettres et des
historiens amateurs ou
semi-professionnels qui s'intéressent
aux questions port royal sur ces mêmes
domaines de recherche
alors il faut savoir qu'il nous arrive
très fréquemment d'évoquer port royal
des champs mais rarement ce lien à louis
xiv qui pour autant et fondamental parce
que c'est la destruction du site de port
royal des champs par le roi soleil qui a
fait la renommée de ce lieu et qui
constitue une véritable énigme
historique c'est l'unique monnaie
détruit par ce roi très pieux durant son
règne et on écoute tout de suite
laurence plazenet qu'il allait en dire
un peu plus c'était l'occasion de
revenir sur une un sujet est peut-être
une grande énigme de l'histoire à savoir
que nous nous trouvons au monastère de
port royal des champs qui est l'unique
monastère détruit par la volonté du roi
de france
c'est une fin de règne et une histoire
épouvantable
comment le roi de france très chrétien
at il plus persécutés de la sorte un
monastère dans lequel demeurait à
l'époque uniquement 22 religieuse très
âgé et le roi a envoyé plus de 200
gendarmes pour procéder à leur exil à
leur arrestation leur exil dans
différents monastère c'est une page
sanglante un terrible de l'histoire
religieuse et politique de la france
alors sephora pourquoi le site de port
royal étaient détruits alors plusieurs
hypothèses ont été évoquées comme un
complot des jésuites qui étaient les
confesseurs du roi à l'époque pour royal
étant un monastère augustiniens et donc
deux conceptions de la grâce divine
s'affrontaient pour royal critiqué
ouvertement l'absolutisme royal est
considéré qu'il n'y avait pas
d'intermédiaire entre le peuple et dieu
tandis que les jésuites privilégier le
roi comme un intermédiaire entre entre
dieu et son peuple et ainsi le roi
soleil qui a été élevé par les jésuites
qui lui ont donné à croire qu'il fallait
craindre un risque de schisme est une
hérésie ecclésiale a préféré supprimer
le site de port royal est et le danger
politique qu'il représentait pour lui
merci à se fondre à cette exposition à
laquelle sera consacré tout un sujet
dans le kiosque du 28 octobre
et c'est la fin de cette édition je vous
remercie de nous avoir suivis tout de
suite
restez avec nous vous avez rendez vous
avec michael et demi d'euros pour le 7-8
sport nous parlerons notamment de
maurepas qui reprend les matchs de foot
après la coupe de france pour ma part je
vous retrouve demain à 18 heures pour
une nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal
en direct je vous souhaite une très
bonne soirée
il